they've reactivated it.
NOTE CONF
So it's switched off after 15 minutes or whatever.
All right, luckily enough in Texas, but still one.
NOTE CONF
Are you searching to thank you.
OK, good day.
NOTE CONF
There's 200 of you somewhere.
That's alright.
NOTE CONF
Um but you know, by the time I get to
third year lecture, attendance starts to go down.
NOTE CONF
Well, I I'm commenting on that because we've actually got
some interesting and useful stuff to do in the lectures.
NOTE CONF
So even though it's nine o'clock on a Wednesday and
you're used to not coming, this is one worth coming
NOTE CONF
to, I think not least of all, because we're working
through these textbooks.
NOTE CONF
And so a lot of what's going on in the
lectures is me explaining what's happening in the textbooks.
NOTE CONF
The only other resource you'll have, besides the lecture is
the the textbook, and that's an old school way of
NOTE CONF
doing things that maybe you're not used to.
You're more used to getting distilled notes or things like
NOTE CONF
that, Um, but you've got the big bulk of the
textbook, and then the maybe more focused stuff in the
NOTE CONF
lecture.
You really do want to combine the two, I think.
NOTE CONF
OK, but I'll introduce myself.
Uh, Matt, some unfamiliar faces cos I haven't been teaching
NOTE CONF
first year for a while, Matt.
And some familiar ones, Matt Roberts.
NOTE CONF
Um, I do programming languages stuff.
So this is my course.
NOTE CONF
I love this course teaching with Damian.
Who's up the back there.
NOTE CONF
He'll be doing the second half, but I'll be convenient.
So I'm your main stop for everything.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the course has had a redesign this year.
So if you're used to it from a previous year,
NOTE CONF
probably a lot of that goes out the window.
Uh, it's the same material, same learning outcomes, but taught
NOTE CONF
in a different way with a different technology and different
tooling.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so just be aware that you can't rely on
old material as much old exams.
NOTE CONF
In fact, those old exams will have a lot of
very specifically things we're not teaching this year because the
NOTE CONF
tool chain that was used in the previous years, uh,
drove what questions we could ask.
NOTE CONF
And now we've got a completely different tool chain.
Mhm.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the short the short end of it is
that we're going through two books.
NOTE CONF
One is called crafting interpreters, and there's an online version
available.
NOTE CONF
Nice and easy.
It's freely available, and you'll probably just use that.
NOTE CONF
And the other book we're going through is seven languages
in seven weeks, which is available via the library online
NOTE CONF
for anybody seven languages and seven languages.
And you will rely on like, I really want to
NOTE CONF
make this point strongly early on because I know students
aren't in the habit of using textbooks very much.
NOTE CONF
Um, you really will have to use those textbooks, like
even in courses that normally have textbooks, and then you
NOTE CONF
don't use them in this one.
I'm completely relying on them.
NOTE CONF
There'll be a bunch of stuff in there.
It won't be anywhere else.
NOTE CONF
Um, and and they're fairly concise books as well.
So often when you use a textbook, there's a bunch
NOTE CONF
of stuff the lecturer doesn't want to cover.
And so it's better just to go use the lecture
NOTE CONF
notes, because then you won't have to pick through the
stuff that's not really in in this stuff.
NOTE CONF
We're just going top to bottom through the books, and
if there's anything I want you to skip, I'll specifically
NOTE CONF
tell you I want you to skip them.
Uh, so it really is the best way to learn
NOTE CONF
the material first time around.
OK, so the course here is on.
NOTE CONF
It's called programming languages, but that can mean lots of
things.
NOTE CONF
Um, it means we're gonna learn the internals of a
programming language from the language point of view.
NOTE CONF
As in, um, you're used to the you you'll know
about statements and expressions and a bit of grammar and
NOTE CONF
semicolons go here.
We're gonna go way deeper into that.
NOTE CONF
So exactly how languages are put together and we're gonna
go deeper into, uh, how languages are implemented, how you
NOTE CONF
go from the source language to a target language.
So that's compilers or interpreters.
NOTE CONF
So that's why one of the books is writing an
interpreter or writing a compiler.
NOTE CONF
Um, so that's the second key part.
And the third key part is just becoming, uh, more
NOTE CONF
flexible in the in the range of languages that we
can make use of.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna learn new languages in a bit of
a scattershot way to try and broaden our education as
NOTE CONF
programming as programmers, so that if we have to go
for a job that says, Oh, this is a job
NOTE CONF
in Ruby you go?
Sure.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, whatever.
I did, Ruby, and Yeah, OK, you're a bit fresh
NOTE CONF
on Ruby, but we've covered it, and you've understood it.
But even more than that, by doing those, uh, six
NOTE CONF
or so languages that we end up doing 6 to
7 languages, uh, plus java.
NOTE CONF
So the next eight, you start to draw the connections
between all those languages, and that skill works for all
NOTE CONF
of the other languages that come along.
So we don't cover JavaScript, for example.
NOTE CONF
But by the end of this course, you should feel
more confident of being able to jump into a language
NOTE CONF
like JavaScript, even if you haven't before, or a language
like python or any other language that you haven't jumped
NOTE CONF
into before.
Hopefully, your confidence level goes from zero to maybe 60
NOTE CONF
out of 100.
Or I could jump in and get my head around
NOTE CONF
this in a short amount of time if I really
had to.
NOTE CONF
So it's got the final skill as a programmer, right?
Being able to just spread yourself across all the programming
NOTE CONF
languages, use whichever environment you need to with that said,
we are, um, previous versions of the course taught in
NOTE CONF
scarlet, So we will also learn teaching you a more
advanced programming language as a part of the course.
NOTE CONF
We don't do scara this year.
So if you're looking forward to scara, I apologise.
NOTE CONF
Um, we can learn Scala separately if anyone ever wants
to.
NOTE CONF
I am happy to teach Scala, but we do cover
it in the language of the fortnite or whatever we're
NOTE CONF
gonna call it.
It's one of those languages we touch on, but in
NOTE CONF
previous years the whole course was done in Skala.
But it's not anymore.
NOTE CONF
We've backed off to Java for a couple of reasons,
but one is that Java has a bunch of the
NOTE CONF
facilities you want to play with.
Anyway.
NOTE CONF
It's caught up with scarlet in a lot of ways.
Another really key and important reason is that scale is
NOTE CONF
not.
Five years ago scale.
NOTE CONF
There was an opportunity for our students to leapfrog people
from other universities and get the jobs they wanted because
NOTE CONF
Scala was the hot thing in industry.
But it's not anymore.
NOTE CONF
So we're not really giving you any value out in
that sense at the moment, so we're probably better off
NOTE CONF
from your point of view of becoming a really good
Java programmer.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and Java feels old fashioned, I'm sure feels old
fashioned.
NOTE CONF
But just recently the biggest employer of software engineers in
Australia, Atlassian just recommitted to Java as their primary language.
NOTE CONF
Um, so it might be old fashioned, but it's still
at the bleeding edge.
NOTE CONF
Uh, well, yeah, probably.
Atlassian probably feels like an old stodgy company to you,
NOTE CONF
but to me it still feels like a start up
because that's what it was in 25 26 27.
NOTE CONF
OK, questions.
There's lots of things to go through in the unit
NOTE CONF
guy.
But before we start anything anyone wants to ask Now
NOTE CONF
the online people, I better try and get an online.
Ah, two or three hours, Um, we've got the three
NOTE CONF
hour spread.
We won't use it unless we need it.
NOTE CONF
So that was a mistake, that they gave us the
three hours.
NOTE CONF
But if we've got interesting things to say and because
there's lots of interesting things to say, we may use
NOTE CONF
it.
But I wouldn't be offended if anyone just walked out
NOTE CONF
after two hours.
Cos they're like, Oh, no, I've only got two hours.
NOTE CONF
It's a lot to listen to in one hit three
hours.
NOTE CONF
Uh, too much.
And especially when we get to the weeks where we
NOTE CONF
do a new language, there's quite a lot to talk
about and quite a lot of things we can go
NOTE CONF
through.
Uh, and I no need to short change you if
NOTE CONF
we've got the opportunity, right?
So the cycle is Each week we'll do something from
NOTE CONF
the crafting interpreters book one by one by one by
one by one.
NOTE CONF
And we'll get all the way through to implementing classes
with inheritance in that book.
NOTE CONF
And then every second week, we'll also take a look
at a new language from the seven languages in Seven
NOTE CONF
Weeks book.
So that week is a busy, hard a week with
NOTE CONF
basically twice as much material.
So you think of it as Easy week.
NOTE CONF
Hard week, easy week, hard week, But the language of
the week stuff the language of the fortnight.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, we used to do S.
We used to do one language every week, but we
NOTE CONF
back that off a bit.
Um, that can be spread over those two weeks.
NOTE CONF
You've got the book, you know it and we're gonna
ask you to read, and so you don't have to
NOTE CONF
just wait until they talk about it to read it.
You can, uh I'd encourage you over the two weeks
NOTE CONF
of the week leading up to that topic to read
that chapter of the book so that when we get
NOTE CONF
to it, uh, you're not having to do double the
work in one week and half the work in the
NOTE CONF
other week.
Another important thing to say is that there's a lot
NOTE CONF
in this course.
Um and if you're I want to be explicit that
NOTE CONF
the the stuff we're doing on the seven languages seven
weeks, uh, is going to be partitioned into a kind
NOTE CONF
of distinction part of the course.
And what I mean by that is we're gonna make
NOTE CONF
sure people who don't understand anything about those languages can
still scrape a pass.
NOTE CONF
And I wanna put that sign posts down so that
any of you get overwhelmed during semester.
NOTE CONF
Know what you can put aside to focus on to
get your pass and not stress, right?
NOTE CONF
So we want everybody to learn everything.
But if you're finding yourself spread too thin and overwhelmed
NOTE CONF
at some point in the course, you can just put
aside the language of the fortnight.
NOTE CONF
Know that you're losing marks.
But know that we've constructed the assessments so that you
NOTE CONF
can if you do well on the other part, still
get your part.
NOTE CONF
But it'll just be a bare pass, right, OK, there's
lots of OKs cos I don't have a good flow
NOTE CONF
when I'm doing these first lectures Topic So the languages
we've got here, um, a lot of these are these
NOTE CONF
seven languages.
A lot of them are industry relevant kind of things
NOTE CONF
particularly, uh, Ruby closure.
Haskell and Skala are the kinds of things that you
NOTE CONF
can sometimes use in industry.
They tend to be niche jobs.
NOTE CONF
But the thing about niche programming languages and those niche
jobs is that once you know how how to programme
NOTE CONF
them, you're in very high demand.
Um, there might be, I don't know, maybe four companies
NOTE CONF
in Sydney right now using has school.
But those four companies are actively chasing developers and paying
NOTE CONF
them very well in their very nice work environments.
So that's what you're getting into when you're learning these
NOTE CONF
languages that maybe it's not your python.
It's not your javascript.
NOTE CONF
It's not your java.
Um, but that's those.
NOTE CONF
And then IO and prologue are really intellectual curiosities.
But this is a university so we can do intellectual
NOTE CONF
curiosities.
Uh, yeah, it's probably when the prologue in itself is
NOTE CONF
a separate language, but they're at school chromo plain.
That's right.
NOTE CONF
Prologue is a way of programme, and and in fact,
most of these seven languages try and touch on different
NOTE CONF
aspects of programming.
So Ruby's looking at the very object oriented, dynamic approach.
NOTE CONF
I haven't read up on the IO chapter remind myself
what IO is talking about.
NOTE CONF
But prologue is the, um, logic style of programming, which
does still have a case.
NOTE CONF
Scala is a kitchen sink language gives you every possible,
uh, approach you want.
NOTE CONF
Erlang is a distributed language for writing servers.
Closure is, uh, the modern version of the oldest languages
NOTE CONF
around, like scheme and high school is what happens if
you take functional programming to its logical extreme.
NOTE CONF
And so you'll get to see all those different facets
of programming and you may never write a logic programme.
NOTE CONF
But by knowing how prologue works, you'll know how to
incorporate logic programming in a Java programme.
NOTE CONF
Same thing as high school.
You might never write a high school programme, but by
NOTE CONF
learning how school it should make, um, generics and lambdas
on the Java side make more sense now on the
NOTE CONF
crafting interpreter side of things, we are doing the the
book's split in two.
NOTE CONF
It's got an interpreter and a compiler, Um, one's written
in Java and one's written in C.
NOTE CONF
We're doing the Java half, which is writing an interpreter
in Java from scratch all the nitty gritty.
NOTE CONF
So there's a lot of code in there and then,
along the way, learning the theory that goes alongside it.
NOTE CONF
But perhaps, if not the depth you might in another
course is more practically oriented.
NOTE CONF
So this is the all the topics you need to
get through to write an interpreter, and they're all there
NOTE CONF
except for classes in inheritance, which are optional.
Um, you only need to add those to your interpreter
NOTE CONF
if you have an object oriented interpreter, object and language.
But this one is so they're in there, and it's
NOTE CONF
an interesting topic but really well crafted book.
So we're really pleased to have that one available to
NOTE CONF
work from, and in both cases, these are really well
written books.
NOTE CONF
We use them because we couldn't really write better, even
if we wanted to.
NOTE CONF
Um And so that's me re encouraging you to give
these books the attention they deserve.
NOTE CONF
Even though it's, uh, not a habit.
I'm sure to pick up a textbook and read it
NOTE CONF
front to back now with all these different languages, Um,
getting a development environment set up can be a little
NOTE CONF
bit tricky.
The labs currently aren't set up for our seven languages,
NOTE CONF
but they are set up for our Java.
Uh, on your personal machine, you'd have to install eight
NOTE CONF
different programming languages to get this working.
And you're welcome to do that.
NOTE CONF
They're all relatively easy.
I is the only one that gives me any trouble,
NOTE CONF
Uh, on an install, because they're all very, uh Well,
well, uh, supported languages Pakistan.
NOTE CONF
But at the same time, I'm gonna do all my
development using VS code with the docker, and that'll make
NOTE CONF
your life easier as well.
So I'd encourage you all if you haven't used docker
NOTE CONF
slash You've used VS code before.
If you haven't used docker before, do that and I'll
NOTE CONF
talk you through how that works when I show you
in today's lecture like that means installing the docker client
NOTE CONF
on your machine.
It means you need a fairly beefy machine, though.
NOTE CONF
Don't use Docker if you've got a, uh, say 2015
or earlier computer.
NOTE CONF
Um, and it wouldn't work on a chromebook either, but
anything that's reasonably beefy should be just fine.
NOTE CONF
Um, for doing the VS code docker combination.
So that's what this this link down here is.
NOTE CONF
I'll show you where that that's my, uh, config for
Docker so that you can all copy my config and
NOTE CONF
get everything I have.
So the flow of the course so every week should
NOTE CONF
look largely the same.
When you open it up, you'll see an overview with
NOTE CONF
the the learning outcomes.
For the week, you'll see links to the readings that
NOTE CONF
we're expecting you to do specifically Chapter one and Chapter
two from crafting interpreters and the introduction from sermon languages.
NOTE CONF
Doing these beforehand is a very, very, very good idea,
and, uh, you probably don't read for leisure, but this
NOTE CONF
is leisurely reading.
These books are set up so that you can actually
NOTE CONF
just sit down with just the book, not have to
be typing along the way and just read them and
NOTE CONF
and take in what they're saying and save the activities
for later.
NOTE CONF
There are activities to do all the time, but the
both of them are books that you can read as
NOTE CONF
a as a book themselves and then the activities you
do separately, rather than there are some books where unless
NOTE CONF
you're doing the activities, nothing is really making any sense.
And then each week we will include the glossary.
NOTE CONF
What the glossary is is any time the books are
using a term that we don't think you've already learned,
NOTE CONF
we stick it in there and give a clear, clear
explanation of it.
NOTE CONF
So instead of giving separate nodes to cover the gaps,
we're just going like, ah, topic by topic.
NOTE CONF
So maybe the term complete is not something you've understood.
It would have been something you did in in your
NOTE CONF
discrete maths, but maybe it's gone from your brain.
Um, sound is another one stream.
NOTE CONF
So these are There's only four here, and I'm stretching
a bit.
NOTE CONF
Actually, you probably knew what those mean, but, uh, complete
in computer science doesn't mean what it means in English.
NOTE CONF
and neither does sound so just being explicit about what
they mean.
NOTE CONF
Because at one point, the textbook mentions things being complete
and sound.
NOTE CONF
And we could just skip over that or we could
actually help you understand?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, system's coming next.
Yeah, And so then after that, So the Goss Ridge
NOTE CONF
tends to go with the readings, right?
You might just check it first to go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, these are the terms I might not get as
I read and then go and read it.
NOTE CONF
And maybe they make sense in context, and you don't
have to worry about it, and or maybe you need
NOTE CONF
to know them.
And then there's a quiz for your workshop.
NOTE CONF
We're structuring things a bit interesting a bit differently this
year.
NOTE CONF
So this is an experiment that I'm that 90% confident
will work, but in the 10% chance doesn't we will
NOTE CONF
readdress, um, when you come to do your workshop, you
don't have a PDF to work from.
NOTE CONF
You've got a quiz to work from.
But when you open the quiz, um, it's gonna look
NOTE CONF
like a PDF because they're basically all questions where you
write text as your answer.
NOTE CONF
No auto marking none of that.
Um And so this is this Would, if you did
NOTE CONF
a print of this, it'd be like having a PDF
of the worksheet, the exact same kind of questions you
NOTE CONF
would have asked before.
You know, I've got complete challenge one and challenge two
NOTE CONF
from chapter one of the text I've got.
Find a little language you've used somewhere.
NOTE CONF
I've got discuss.
So obviously that's something that's gonna happen in class.
NOTE CONF
Discuss which of the following compilers and which are interpreters.
Um, there are multiple.
NOTE CONF
OK, so those are the activities we're expecting you to
do.
NOTE CONF
They as always, you should.
If you look at them and try them beforehand, that's
NOTE CONF
all the better.
But they should just be able to squeeze into a
NOTE CONF
two hour workshop if everything goes well.
So that's why you wanna look at them beforehand to
NOTE CONF
work out where you might have trouble to make sure
the workshop goes in that direction.
NOTE CONF
But if you turn up and walk through a workshop,
then you should get a chance to go through all
NOTE CONF
these questions.
Um, and then you'll save and review and submit a
NOTE CONF
whenever middle and finish.
Um, and you'll have here.
NOTE CONF
I've got zero, but you shouldn't have a question mark
out of 100.
NOTE CONF
I got zero because I didn't submit anything.
And it knows if I didn't submit anything, it's gonna
NOTE CONF
be zero.
Maybe I should redo it, but you'll see a question
NOTE CONF
mark out of 100 here up here and a mo
question Mark added.
NOTE CONF
Two appear here.
And none of that matters because you'll see the correct
NOTE CONF
answers included here in your review so you can review
your ques, the questions, your answers, the correct answers.
NOTE CONF
They can all be reviewed.
So that's our way of delivering worksheets.
NOTE CONF
And in fact, you can get access to the correct
answers before you turn up to class.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the point of class is not to give you
the correct answers.
NOTE CONF
Those are there in the quiz.
You attempt the quiz, you'll see them.
NOTE CONF
The point of class is to create an environment in
which you can learn the things you need to learn
NOTE CONF
to pass.
The course comes later.
NOTE CONF
Um, now that means getting to the answers, but getting
to the answers in a collaborative way with your with
NOTE CONF
your colleagues and working through things and discussing the tricky
parts.
NOTE CONF
So that experience of turning up to the workshop is
compulsory in this course.
NOTE CONF
And the way we enforce the compulsory nature of it
is that, um, sometime after the submissions finished and the
NOTE CONF
week's finished your class teacher, we'll go through and just
tick off your attendance and your mark will go from
NOTE CONF
question mark up to 100.
Won't matter what your answer was as long as you
NOTE CONF
got a genuine attempt at the answer.
That's good.
NOTE CONF
Uh, they're not checking to see whether it's correct or
incorrect.
NOTE CONF
They're checking to see whether you've made an attempt at
the questions you may attempt at the questions you can
NOTE CONF
turn up to class.
Then, oh, you'll get your 100 out of 100 and
NOTE CONF
your two out of two, right?
If those D you don't count for grades, but they
NOTE CONF
are needed to get access to the exams.
So unless you've got the grades in those we weekly
NOTE CONF
quizzes ticked off, the exams won't become available to you.
They won't be visible.
NOTE CONF
You know what I mean.
And so you'll need to attend those.
NOTE CONF
And then if, of course, if you can't attend a
class you put in a special consideration.
NOTE CONF
You still submit the answers online when you get the
chance.
NOTE CONF
And instead of your class tutor ticking you off, whoever
processes your special consideration goes in and looks for the
NOTE CONF
genuine attempts and ticks them off.
So if you can't physically attend, you still do the
NOTE CONF
work.
But you put in that special consideration so that we
NOTE CONF
can pick it up questions on that, OK, and then
under assessments, each exam that we've got here.
NOTE CONF
So 60% of the course is exams.
There's three of those.
NOTE CONF
Did you say 322 of those two of those.
There's two of those, um, but they're broken into two
NOTE CONF
parts, so every each of the two exams that comes
along you have a take home section called the pass
NOTE CONF
exam that you got a whole week to do.
It's timed, so once you start it, you've only got
NOTE CONF
a certain number of minutes to finish it.
But you're doing it at home when you want online,
NOTE CONF
and that can get you up to 65% of the
points for that exam.
NOTE CONF
That exam will not be available unless you've attended class.
So if you don't attend class and you won't even
NOTE CONF
see that it'll say not available unless you've achieved high
on a certain score.
NOTE CONF
And that's the way it's compulsory because these ones do
get grades.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's a whole week To get that done
at your leisure and get three attempts and get the
NOTE CONF
highest grade you can.
If your grade goes above a certain grade, which we've
NOTE CONF
set at 77% for the 65% then a distinction exam
becomes available.
NOTE CONF
But the distinction exam is harder.
Questions in person on campus.
NOTE CONF
One shot right?
So you've got the take home opportunity to rack up
NOTE CONF
your pass.
But to really get good marks, you've got to turn
NOTE CONF
up to that in-person exam where it's much higher stakes,
higher pressure.
NOTE CONF
It's like an old school exam, but there there'll be
multiple times scheduled, and you'll be picking your time.
NOTE CONF
So as soon as it becomes available, you see a
little chance to pick the the time you wanna sit
NOTE CONF
the exam.
You pick your time, you turn up, you've got access
NOTE CONF
to the exam on, I learn, and you answer those
more difficult questions.
NOTE CONF
It tends to be about a 20 minute set up.
So not long, Um, which means in total there's really
NOTE CONF
only like an hour's worth and a half's worth of
exams.
NOTE CONF
But on one of those exams you're doing multiple attempts,
the other one you're preparing for beforehand and so on
NOTE CONF
and so forth.
And then because we don't, uh, yes.
NOTE CONF
So if you put on the first exam, you can
get a special one.
NOTE CONF
Um, you can get a what?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
So if you get full marks on the first exam,
that will be 65% of that exams.
NOTE CONF
Grades?
Yeah, making sense.
NOTE CONF
So if you own, if you do 100% on both
the two past exams and never sat at a distinction
NOTE CONF
exam, you'd end up with a 65 for your exam
are 55% of your exam are the critic Justin, and
NOTE CONF
then the other 35% are are is only available to
people who turn up to the in person exam.
NOTE CONF
So you get to choose.
Um, this is another way.
NOTE CONF
We give you a bit of agency over your learning
where you want to put your effort.
NOTE CONF
If you're struggling with other courses you get the opportunity
and it's delineated, too, So you know where to spend
NOTE CONF
your time and energy.
And if you've yeah, so we don't have past exams
NOTE CONF
for you to work off.
Because, of course, it's changed quite a bit.
NOTE CONF
So for each exam within a, let's say, a week
before the, uh, exams gonna become available, um, there'll be
NOTE CONF
a practise exam available, which has versions of all of
the past and distinction questions in there.
NOTE CONF
And that'll again be ex uh, presented to you as
a I learn quiz.
NOTE CONF
But it's not worth any marks, and you can do
it over and over again.
NOTE CONF
And there's a there'll be multiple questions that appear that
change every time until you run out of options and
NOTE CONF
so you can go in there to do your prep
for your exams because you're gonna have past exams to
NOTE CONF
go on, and they will be very closely related question
questions on that.
NOTE CONF
So, um, in class, we turn up to class so
we can get access to the exam.
NOTE CONF
We do the practise exam to prepare, which is at
home whenever we want.
NOTE CONF
Multiple times we do the pass exam in the scheduled
week at home multiple times, and then we turn up
NOTE CONF
for the distinction exam.
So because of all this complexity, we've only got two
NOTE CONF
of these to do.
We got one and around the middle of semester and
NOTE CONF
one around the end of semester, the one around the
end of the semester.
NOTE CONF
The distinction part will be in the exam period.
So even though there's not an exam scheduled on the
NOTE CONF
exam period, if you wanna sit that second distinction paper,
you've got to come in the exam period.
NOTE CONF
But it's early in the exam period.
The other one's happening around the mid semester break, whether
NOTE CONF
it's cos I got two courses running at once, so
I don't I can't remember whether this one is in
NOTE CONF
the mid semester break or the week before.
Do Exam car.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'll come.
So do these exams involve writing code Code Runner or
NOTE CONF
some?
They certainly involve writing code.
NOTE CONF
Um, Code Runner will be used for the past exams
because you've got multiple chances that we need to auto
NOTE CONF
mark every one of those questions.
So we need to rely on multiple choices matching questions
NOTE CONF
and code runner.
But the distinction exam could have sections with no code
NOTE CONF
runner.
But you're still asked to write some code and that
NOTE CONF
code goes in a text box and we mark it
by hand.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna use code run if we can.
Um, but as you're gonna get to see to it,
NOTE CONF
there's a lot of machinery in this course.
We can ask you questions that require you to make
NOTE CONF
changes across three files, and then it's a real hassle
to make that work in code runner.
NOTE CONF
Whereas if your codes are, if your changes are restricted
to one file or something, I can generally make that
NOTE CONF
work.
Um, yeah, but we really do push the limits of
NOTE CONF
what programme can do, so we use it where we
can, But it certainly helps a lot for us to
NOTE CONF
be able to do our cos this is a co
heavy course.
NOTE CONF
Very, very heavy course.
Um, but you're gonna find a fair number of conceptual
NOTE CONF
questions in that past exam because just of the nature
of wanting to ask multiple choice matching style questions and
NOTE CONF
also things that you know, students at a past level
can answer.
NOTE CONF
But you should expect the distinction exam mostly to be
just kind of coding something up.
NOTE CONF
Uh, in most cases, there's gonna be a variant of
the compiler or the interpreter that we're working through in
NOTE CONF
class.
So that one from locks when it comes to the
NOTE CONF
seven languages, we may ask you to write code in
one of those languages.
NOTE CONF
Uh, code runner doesn't support any of them.
So that would have to be hand marked, But it's
NOTE CONF
much more likely we'll ask you to interpret code in
that language because the depth at which we're hitting those
NOTE CONF
seven languages, we're not learning them as programmers.
We're learning them to broaden that now.
NOTE CONF
I might write some code and say, Look what's gonna
happen when this code runs in Ruby versus when it
NOTE CONF
runs in pipe and or when it runs in Java,
Then you can answer me that question rather than say,
NOTE CONF
you know, right, a greatest common divisor in I'm not
gonna ask that.
NOTE CONF
OK, are they Christian?
So that's covered the exams and then we've got three
NOTE CONF
assignments.
They are labelled advanced programming language features, syntax, analysis and
NOTE CONF
translation.
Uh, this one's done early.
NOTE CONF
This one's done in the middle.
This one's done towards the end, Um, still a little
NOTE CONF
bit up in the air on exactly what that first
one's gonna be.
NOTE CONF
Um, I'll give you a hypothetical.
The hypothetical is that all three of them are extensions
NOTE CONF
to the interpreter we're creating through the Crafting Interpreters book.
Certainly, the assignments are just crafty interpreters.
NOTE CONF
They're not based on the language, the seven languages.
That's theoretical, not practical material.
NOTE CONF
The the possible variant to that is that the first
one might be writing code in the lock language, which
NOTE CONF
is the language.
Our interpreter works on you.
NOTE CONF
You'll understand when we get to next week.
So we're writing an interpreter for you can't write an
NOTE CONF
interpreter for We're not writing an interpreter for Java or
C or anything like that.
NOTE CONF
We're writing an interpreter for a brand new language called
Locks, which is described in the textbook.
NOTE CONF
So we're still not sure if we're gonna ask you
to write lock code in the first assessment, or if
NOTE CONF
we're gonna ask you to to write a bit on
the interpreter in the first assessment.
NOTE CONF
But for the second one, you'll definitely be extending the
interpreter to do extra syntax analysis for extra forms and
NOTE CONF
then you'll be doing the same thing.
Extending that interpreter to do translation and evaluation and in
NOTE CONF
the second pot.
And those are also the same kinds of activities you'll
NOTE CONF
be doing in the workshops in the classes.
Uh, not class one, but class two already has you
NOTE CONF
making, um, extensions to that locks interpreter.
And so you'll basically have a more complicated and more
NOTE CONF
interesting extension to the locks.
Interpreter, The mic in your own time at heart.
NOTE CONF
OK, uh, so you end up This is one of
the problems with the older course is that you end
NOTE CONF
up being thrown a A.
You probably had this in other courses.
NOTE CONF
You get a big code base like, because it's too
much for you to do the concepts.
NOTE CONF
You couldn't go from scratch and get them done in
the amount of time available in a university course.
NOTE CONF
I couldn't say to you, but write a new interpreter
from scratch as part of this course.
NOTE CONF
So in the past, and then maybe in other courses,
people give you scaffolding and tooling and a half written
NOTE CONF
programme.
You've probably experienced this in 2000 where recognising as well,
NOTE CONF
you know, you've got this programme and you've got to
make small changes to this programme to make something work
NOTE CONF
right.
And that's not doesn't work well for a lot of
NOTE CONF
our students.
The advantage here is you're still doing the same thing
NOTE CONF
here, but the advantage we've the the improvement we've made
Is there an entire textbook describing that code?
NOTE CONF
And that's what we're focusing on.
And so, yes, it will be like, Oh, there's a
NOTE CONF
big the locks interpreter already exists.
I've already got, you know, 500 lines of code to
NOTE CONF
start from, and Matt's asking me to add another production,
which means I've gotta change this bit here and this
NOTE CONF
bit here.
But hopefully it's not so much of a scavenger hunt
NOTE CONF
for you guys because the book that we've covered has
led us up to that point really nicely.
NOTE CONF
Whereas in previous years we couldn't spend that much time
explaining the interpreter itself, cos we were spending too much
NOTE CONF
time explaining Scala, Uh, but we're back in Java so
we don't have to go back and redo Java, although
NOTE CONF
you will refresh your Java skill.
OK, so two exam sets three assessment sets.
NOTE CONF
The first assessment set is relatively small um, but it's
still worth a good 10%.
NOTE CONF
So that's probably the easiest 10% to rack up in
the course.
NOTE CONF
And it'll be quite soon.
I think it's week three or four.
NOTE CONF
so that will be released very soon.
Any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Were you all happy?
Any concerns?
NOTE CONF
Anything you don't like.
I can't change anything after a little while.
NOTE CONF
If anyone's like that.
Sounds horrible.
NOTE CONF
And I don't want to do it.
I might not change it, but you can tell me
NOTE CONF
now so I can at least know.
No.
NOTE CONF
OK, alright.
We're good to go then.
NOTE CONF
OK, so should be fun.
Uh, our teaching assistants at the moment we've got, uh,
NOTE CONF
Zlin who's new to Macquarie, but definitely not new to
teaching and not new to programming languages.
NOTE CONF
And we've got Angus, who many of you have probably
had before in your classes.
NOTE CONF
That'll be really good.
Um, the course numbers are growing, and we have to
NOTE CONF
keep opening new classes.
So some of you still don't have classes allocated.
NOTE CONF
Uh, they did just open a brand new one.
Maybe Someone you probably know about classes allocated by now,
NOTE CONF
right?
I don't know if you can check to see if
NOTE CONF
there's free classes.
Actually, you probably can, Right?
NOTE CONF
Um, they last night they emailed me to say they
released another one, but I haven't, um, had a chance
NOTE CONF
to chase that up.
But even once that one's done, it'll still be pretty
NOTE CONF
full as well.
So in this first week, anyone who's not allocated classes
NOTE CONF
should just turn up to what they can because First
Week's compulsory.
NOTE CONF
In that sense, we will be generous in ticking off
attendance and everything.
NOTE CONF
But, um, we're just starting.
We're not waiting.
NOTE CONF
We don't have time to dilly dally, and it's much
better to start early.
NOTE CONF
And you if the course runs well and we don't
have any, Um, if we don't go over on anything.
NOTE CONF
Week 13 won't have material, and you'll be focusing on
assessments in Week 12 and 13.
NOTE CONF
Um, which hopefully is nice with your other courses because
you'll hopefully be able to get 3000 out of the
NOTE CONF
way and then worry about the other ones that have
exams.
NOTE CONF
But that's one reason we just hit the ground running.
Um, and this week's workshop for class is on this
NOTE CONF
week's material that we're gonna cover here.
It's always that week.
NOTE CONF
You come to the lecture on a Wednesday morning, and
then your class afterwards is talking about the same material.
NOTE CONF
That's another reason you want to read ahead a bit
because you don't have that week in between the lecture
NOTE CONF
and the class.
Um, it's all happening.
NOTE CONF
It's all happening on that week.
OK, so some people have already submitted, which means some
NOTE CONF
people are well, there we go.
Someone else has submitted glue in, uh, when you look
NOTE CONF
at the grade book, so the grade book is not
100% complete yet, but I do just want to show
NOTE CONF
the, um, the setup that you'll see.
I know it looks a little bit different for you,
NOTE CONF
but you'll see there's an assignments block.
With the three assignments you'll see, there's an exam block
NOTE CONF
where all of the exams will appear, and they'll add
up to 60% in total.
NOTE CONF
And then there'll be a fairly big chunk where lots
of things appear that don't contribute to the final grade.
NOTE CONF
That's where the practise questions are.
That's where the class submissions are.
NOTE CONF
Grades are attached to those that they don't attach to
your final grade.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and the unit guide The unit total won't be
up to date until probably about midway through the course.
NOTE CONF
And then about midway through the course, you should reliably
be able to look at that unit total, uh, to
NOTE CONF
know where you're at.
And so let me know if, after the mid semester
NOTE CONF
break your unit total's not adding up to what you
think it should add up to, because we want every
NOTE CONF
everyone, everyone to have as much information as they can,
especially leading into that last exam knowing what they want
NOTE CONF
to spend their time and effort on.
Should we start?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Good.
NOTE CONF
Got a couple of minutes?
Uh, crafting interpreters.
NOTE CONF
Let's begin.
So it's written by, uh, Nystrom who?
NOTE CONF
I have a vague idea that I might have met
once before, but it would have been just once a
NOTE CONF
long time ago.
Um, but and only a vague memory.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but he's written two really nice books.
So we're using, uh, So it's got, as I said,
NOTE CONF
two chunks.
It's got a tree walk interpreter in part two and
NOTE CONF
a byte code virtual machine.
In part three.
NOTE CONF
We are only doing part two part two is in
Java.
NOTE CONF
Part three is in C.
But, uh, another advantage of this textbook is that those
NOTE CONF
of you who are really interested in what you've learned
in this course can then go ahead and do part
NOTE CONF
three yourself, um, and happy to chat to anyone who's
working through that as well.
NOTE CONF
But it's in C, which is not a core language
for the software, uh, technology or software engineering degrees.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so we would have to spend some time just
making sure everyone's up to speed on C.
NOTE CONF
Um, and there's only so much time in a course,
So we've focused on the first one where it's all
NOTE CONF
written in Java.
It's written in fairly old school java for the to
NOTE CONF
make sure it's accessible to as many people as possible
As we go along, we will, uh, freshen it up
NOTE CONF
and, uh, change some things to make them nicer Java.
And that's something I want you doing along the way.
NOTE CONF
Uh, as you're putting in the code that he's giving,
you want you to think about how it can and
NOTE CONF
should be better, and we'll get questions in workshops and,
uh, forum posts and probably prizes for people who make
NOTE CONF
the best improvements to the code base using newer Java
features.
NOTE CONF
There's lots of little things that crop up along the
way.
NOTE CONF
One of the traps here that we're going to strategize
our way around is the copy paste strap, uh, trap.
NOTE CONF
OK, I'll show you what I mean.
So we're just doing the intro here, but I'm just
NOTE CONF
giving you a little bit of a preview, Uh, once
we get into game.
NOTE CONF
So this is next week's material, and the way the
book works is it explains what's going on and then
NOTE CONF
gives you the actual Java code from the Interpreter and
you're creating your own interpreter alongside.
NOTE CONF
So you've got to put that same code into your
interpreter and maybe on the first one you start typing
NOTE CONF
it and you get to import dot java dot I
a.gov.
NOTE CONF
Oh, God, you're done.
You copy.
NOTE CONF
Paste it instead.
Ok, that's totally natural.
NOTE CONF
I do the same thing.
The strategies we have to work around that Copy paste
NOTE CONF
is that we've got text above and below that we
make sure we're reading, so we understand what it does.
NOTE CONF
And every time we copy paste, we look for something
we can improve in that with the new Java features.
NOTE CONF
And so we don't have to actually type to to
to all the characters in we're not gonna be able
NOTE CONF
to beat our tendency to copy and paste the block
and put it in.
NOTE CONF
But we are gonna have some change that has to
be made or could be made.
NOTE CONF
That's gonna make us address that code when we copy
it in.
NOTE CONF
So one of the things I've done in mine is
that all my classes have completely have different names instead
NOTE CONF
of the language being called locks.
It's called Matlock Professor, and I'm gonna get a picture
NOTE CONF
of the character.
Ma, you're too younger than Matlock.
NOTE CONF
He was a TV detective or a lawyer.
Um, mine's called Matlock.
NOTE CONF
And so I can't just copy paste cos all the
locks have to turn in the mat locks.
NOTE CONF
That's just a tiny thing, but it makes me address
the code as I go in.
NOTE CONF
And once I commit to it, I made a Matlock
and a mat scanner and a mat parser and a
NOTE CONF
mat.
Whatever.
NOTE CONF
Um, it becomes too much work to go back and
go back to his one, and I'm stuck with it
NOTE CONF
and I But it's that little just that.
Just that little requirement to address the code as a
NOTE CONF
go lock.
So I encourage you to all do the same.
NOTE CONF
So maybe come up your little language won't be locks.
It'll be something locks or something.
NOTE CONF
You know, if you're doing programming languages, you've gotta do
puns.
NOTE CONF
That's what programming language people do.
So, uh, can someone guess if you haven't read it
NOTE CONF
already?
What?
NOTE CONF
The pun with locks is nine.
Uh, I haven't actually double checked, but I think, uh,
NOTE CONF
Robert's Danish or Swedish and it's got something to do
with grave lock, which is some pickled fish.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, taking care of everything.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Um, but the Matlock one is obviously obvious.
That's Matt Locks.
NOTE CONF
Plus, it's a dude.
See if you can come up with a fun pun
NOTE CONF
for your name.
Alright, but back to the actual stuff we're covering this
NOTE CONF
week.
So introduction map of the territory and we get into
NOTE CONF
locks.
Language.
NOTE CONF
Next.
Oh, actually, scanning is week three.
NOTE CONF
Not week.
Two locks.
NOTE CONF
Language is week two.
Oh, there's design notes working in the name.
NOTE CONF
If you got it down the bottom somewhere.
Oh, no, He doesn't make the point of whether it's
NOTE CONF
why he's gone with locks in that part.
OK, uh, so these things he's written the textbook in
NOTE CONF
a really nice way.
It's got the main text down the bottom.
NOTE CONF
It's got these asides over here, but they're very, uh,
to them.
NOTE CONF
They're important for us in particular, because often what he's
putting in the aside is the theoretical underpinning that we
NOTE CONF
care about.
Static type systems in particular require rigorous formal reasoning acumen
NOTE CONF
type systems.
So this line here that matters in this course I'm
NOTE CONF
probably gonna ask questions about that.
Whereas it doesn't, it's not needed to write the the
NOTE CONF
interpreter.
So make sure you, uh, don't skim over those.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and things like this.
I mean, this one's a little historical side, but they're
NOTE CONF
the kind of things I could ask you about and
that, like you transfer me card.
NOTE CONF
So why, why?
But I like this line here, and this is this
NOTE CONF
is a good way to think of this course we're
gonna spend mostly spend our brain juice getting the language
NOTE CONF
up and running.
Um, but this is a university course, so you'll find
NOTE CONF
me leaning a bit more heavily.
I want to warn you about it a bit more
NOTE CONF
heavily on the theory than than is suggested in the
book.
NOTE CONF
I.
I mean, I if there's a theory being in there,
NOTE CONF
I'm probably gonna ask you about it.
But solid intuition for how real language lives and breathes
NOTE CONF
is, uh, a nice way to describe it too.
So I learn this.
NOTE CONF
So, um, you'll probably never write yourself a compiler.
Noone.
NOTE CONF
Noone here is sitting.
Well, maybe if anyone here is sitting and thinking and
NOTE CONF
I want a job writing a compiler, send me an
email straight away.
NOTE CONF
But most of you probably aren't thinking I'd really like
to write a compiler or be a compiler writer in
NOTE CONF
my career.
So why would we do a course where we focus
NOTE CONF
on compiler writing?
First reason is that you probably will end up being
NOTE CONF
a compiler writer.
Uh, because compilers are almost they're like a design pattern
NOTE CONF
in programming.
They are the right solution to a tonne of your
NOTE CONF
problems.
And by knowing how they work and knowing the places
NOTE CONF
to put them in, you'll become a more powerful and
more effective programmer and in particular, you become the guy
NOTE CONF
in the company who goes, Oh, this spaghetti code we've
got everywhere Would you just write a little language for
NOTE CONF
it and a quick compiler and boom and everybody loves
you for the next 20 years?
NOTE CONF
Well, you're guaranteed to be employed because you write the
language and now they need someone who knows the language.
NOTE CONF
But these things tend to be little languages.
They're not full programming languages like python or whatever, but
NOTE CONF
they're small languages addressing a particular problem that your company
has or in your domain matters.
NOTE CONF
And so the you end up writing compilers or interpreters
for little languages.
NOTE CONF
Not big languages, little languages.
You've seen lots of around the place.
NOTE CONF
I don't know how many of these you've actually seen
done.
NOTE CONF
Any Web development you've probably played with Moustache and yo
sweet.
NOTE CONF
If you're on the PHP side of things, you certainly
don't use SQL, and hopefully you use bash as well.
NOTE CONF
All these things that you might think of as programmes
or tools are actually little languages.
NOTE CONF
So what's the difference between a language and a tool
right?
NOTE CONF
When I go to sequel, a type sequel or a
type make.
NOTE CONF
Why am I suggesting that I'm using a programming language
instead of just a programme?
NOTE CONF
It all comes down to how the language or how
the the programme expresses itself.
NOTE CONF
If it's a set of actions that you just do
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, then it's probably just a
NOTE CONF
programme with commands.
But if you have to somehow write down what you
NOTE CONF
want the programme to do along the way, then you've
probably written yourself a little language and that's what all
NOTE CONF
these are.
All these are descriptions that will be sent to another
NOTE CONF
programme and that programme will use it to get its
job done and there's tonnes of times.
NOTE CONF
You want to write down the description of what the
programme should do.
NOTE CONF
The programme can't just know exactly what to do.
You can't just parameterize it with a few command line
NOTE CONF
or a few parameters.
You've actually gotta have fairly detailed descriptions of the different
NOTE CONF
things the programme might choose to do.
Then you end up in language land and you can
NOTE CONF
do it wrong 1000 times over.
If you don't know this stuff and you know this
NOTE CONF
stuff, you just do it right first time.
And just like with any other of the programming patterns
NOTE CONF
you might come across, going through them is good exercise
because it's getting you used to something that you're gonna
NOTE CONF
have to do.
Another one for us here in this course, is that
NOTE CONF
understanding.
What's going on underneath the language and how the language
NOTE CONF
is put together makes you better at picking up new
languages as they come along.
NOTE CONF
You're learning the more fundamental concepts underneath that are more
transferable to other languages.
NOTE CONF
So what I mean by that is that you should
probably have a better idea of what a variable is
NOTE CONF
after this course than you did before.
Even though we don't have a topic.
NOTE CONF
What are variables?
You'll implement variables in a language.
NOTE CONF
You'll parse them.
You'll analyse them and you'll interpret them.
NOTE CONF
And that gives you a deeper understanding of exactly what
a variable is the boundaries of where a variable can
NOTE CONF
operate.
And so then when you see a new language and
NOTE CONF
you see its variables, you know the full scope of
what might be in there.
NOTE CONF
You're not just reading a spec list and trying to
put it into a pigeon hole.
NOTE CONF
Um, but then he's also got here that programming language
is just a They're just good.
NOTE CONF
So programming languages are like the mathematics of computer programming,
you know, in the sense in which you get concise
NOTE CONF
and beautiful things out of them.
Uh, it's way more fun than databases or cloud infrastructure
NOTE CONF
or anything.
It's like just a beautiful constructs.
NOTE CONF
OK, so every line of code in here you can
go and download the locks, interpreters freely available, and then
NOTE CONF
you've got all the code.
But don't do that.
NOTE CONF
That's a waste of your time.
Uh, but all the code in here is actual code
NOTE CONF
from in his interpreter.
So we can feel pretty confident that when we're building
NOTE CONF
ours, we can just take his code and either type
it out again, make it to our changes or copy
NOTE CONF
and paste or whatever, and things will work.
That's a key.
NOTE CONF
Um, philosophy of the book is that every wart is
dealt with.
NOTE CONF
Nothing is glossed over, so we are gonna have to
touch all of the questions that come along.
NOTE CONF
There's a temptation when you write a book like this
to go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, goodness me.
This this concept is too hard, but I want to
NOTE CONF
include it.
So I'll stick it in a library and they can
NOTE CONF
download the library and just use it.
You can do that no matter what it is.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna have a line of Java code that does
it for 10 lines of Java code that as a
NOTE CONF
part of that, the language ends up quite small because
there's a lot of things you can't add without adding
NOTE CONF
complexity.
But guess what?
NOTE CONF
In this course, we're gonna grow it a little bit
because we're gonna add a couple of those things that
NOTE CONF
aren't in there.
And we're gonna write that code, and we're gonna deal
NOTE CONF
with that complexity.
And so the asides over here are outside.
NOTE CONF
They're not asides to us.
They're important.
NOTE CONF
Um, that's a good point.
Here.
NOTE CONF
The challenge is often ask your 18 just to interpret
your building, and you wanna interpret those if you want
NOTE CONF
to put those in a copy of your code.
So what I was suggesting before about having small changes
NOTE CONF
for yours is that separate to this?
Um, what he's talking about here is that if you're
NOTE CONF
doing some of the challenges, they might tell you swap
out double slashes for comments, turn them into hashes for
NOTE CONF
comments.
So you change your interpreter to do comments that, uh,
NOTE CONF
hashes for comments.
And then if you keep using that 13 chapters later,
NOTE CONF
he's gonna use hashes for something else, and it won't
fit with your version.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so that's what it means there.
And when you're making changes to the how it actually
NOTE CONF
works rather than just, you know, a couple of names
here or some what we we're doing when we turn
NOTE CONF
things into more modern java refactoring we're just the code
still works exactly the same.
NOTE CONF
We're just picking different language constructs.
Um, that's all fine to do in in the one
NOTE CONF
copy that you're working from.
It's just implementing extras might require, uh might clash with
NOTE CONF
things later on.
As we go through the workshops, we'll be asking you
NOTE CONF
to put extras in, um and we'll let you know
if they G they're gonna clash.
NOTE CONF
You can keep working on the same workshop code and
it can have the changes.
NOTE CONF
And then when we get to a bit where that
that workshop code's gonna have problems, we'll let you know.
NOTE CONF
Um and In most cases it won't but yeah, but
we are messing about with the hashes and the the
NOTE CONF
character.
Oh, is that in the workshops or in our Christian
NOTE CONF
who can remember not me, you'll find out and on.
Here also is the design.
NOTE CONF
He does spend some time talking about the designer language.
It's a fairly simple language.
NOTE CONF
It's not a huge amount of design to get into,
but it touches on here, and we learn a lot
NOTE CONF
more of that with our seven languages because we're seeing
the alternatives, the alternative designs that are out there.
NOTE CONF
So there's infinitely many ways to write programming languages.
Uh, but there's not infinitely many languages, right?
NOTE CONF
So there must be some guiding design principles that that
matter and that people are using for us to end
NOTE CONF
up at fairly similar languages over and over.
OK, so his interpreter is called J lock for Java
NOTE CONF
locks cos he's also got a Is it a sea
locks letter on, and he explains why he uses Java.
NOTE CONF
This book is actually a little bit old, and when
he wrote this D it was probably a bit behind,
NOTE CONF
not super.
I was fairly new, but Java had a real vibe
NOTE CONF
of being falling out of date because I think languages
like Clan and Scala and Rust were starting to eat
NOTE CONF
his lunch a little bit.
So he makes a big point out of why J.
NOTE CONF
But these days, actually, I don't think people would ask
quite as much because clan's dying and Scar's dead and
NOTE CONF
is back on top again.
So, uh, maybe you, um, but also, the thing to
NOTE CONF
note is that Oracle have been doing a good job
of updating Java as it goes along.
NOTE CONF
It's a language that's evolving.
You mix that point here, I think.
NOTE CONF
Is this the one where he talks about evolving languages?
What do you have to Yeah, Java's evolving and that
NOTE CONF
Evo evolution of a language is really important as well.
You can think of languages that don't evolve, Um, but
NOTE CONF
even languages like C are evolving.
There's different C standards that come out.
NOTE CONF
But C++, for example, definitely evolves quite a lot, and
Java's doing that as well.
NOTE CONF
And that's what the successful languages do, so they don't
just sit still and stay the way they were and
NOTE CONF
managing that evolution is difficult and there are plenty of
examples of languages that have failed in trying to make
NOTE CONF
evolutionary jumps.
But, uh, Oracle are succeeding so far with each other.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we won't worry about the second interpreter.
That's a picture of someone pulling themselves up by their
NOTE CONF
bootstraps.
And then in most of the chapters, there are challenges
NOTE CONF
here, and you're definitely encouraged to do the challenges.
And certainly, I'll tell you specifically to do them this
NOTE CONF
week.
Um, but I will tell you if I think the
NOTE CONF
challenges are particularly good, they'll be in the workshop.
Please do the challenge question.
NOTE CONF
So if I tell you to do that because I
really think they're good if I don't tell you to
NOTE CONF
them, they're still good.
But, uh, there are maybe other things I would to
NOTE CONF
put the the spotlight on.
Or maybe I think they're a little bit too much
NOTE CONF
of a challenge.
These ones definitely aren't a challenge, but we're in the
NOTE CONF
first chapter later on.
They do get to be bit of a challenge, but
NOTE CONF
they're all good, all good and then design notes are
also a part of the course.
NOTE CONF
Please don't Don't ignore that, Um, but picking a name
for a language is, uh, part of the fun.
NOTE CONF
So did you know languages with names like C C's?
OK, cos it's so popular.
NOTE CONF
But if you named a language P, you'd never be
able to Google for it.
NOTE CONF
So half the problem is being out of Google for
the language.
NOTE CONF
Which means this is why these points come up, you
know, it's not in use.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's gotta be easy to pronounce.
The people can talk about it, which is a problem
NOTE CONF
that's come up with some other languages that have recently
renamed themselves The Rock a much nicer name and, uh,
NOTE CONF
doesn't have negative connotations, but I think he was talking
about Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So, Nim, I don't know, Nim.
OK, so numero got converted in because numero is an
NOTE CONF
offence to term that I used to copy what you
wrote, but I'm much, much kinder now.
NOTE CONF
All right, questions on our first chapter of christing interpreters,
you know.
NOTE CONF
Oh, good.
OK, next now there would normally be a lot more
NOTE CONF
coding than talking.
We've normally got a bunch of java code in front
NOTE CONF
of us to talk about to go through, but not
this first week map of the territory.
NOTE CONF
Yes, maps are good, and he's got quite a nice
one, as you'll see when you get through the workshops.
NOTE CONF
Just as there are infinitely many ways to write a
programming language, there are infinitely many possible combinations you can
NOTE CONF
put together for writing an interpreter or a compiler.
We obviously end up with just one here, Um, but
NOTE CONF
the diagram here is trying to express that not every
interpreter or compile you see is really the same.
NOTE CONF
Um, so the analogy he's got here is that it's
a mountain.
NOTE CONF
So the first thing to say is Al always with
programming or programming language implementation.
NOTE CONF
We're taking source code, which is something that's human, readable
but completely precise.
NOTE CONF
So a programme can execute it and convey it into
machine code, which is just as precise but doesn't have
NOTE CONF
to be human readable.
So one question should immediately come to mind.
NOTE CONF
Why do we call that?
Why would I bother taking something that had two good
NOTE CONF
properties and turn it into something that has one good
property?
NOTE CONF
You been readable and precise.
You can go just precise thought so they can read
NOTE CONF
the the the computer.
Then they can read English because that's it's good cos
NOTE CONF
that's what we're gonna make it do.
That's precise.
NOTE CONF
The computer can read it.
Why are we using machine code efficiency?
NOTE CONF
That's the one, UM, source code.
Can't be run as efficiently machines, but it can be
NOTE CONF
wrong.
And what we end up seeing here is that we
NOTE CONF
as we translate across this mountain where taking away impediments
to efficiency, we're not adding more precision.
NOTE CONF
It's all precise.
Ah, that's a lie.
NOTE CONF
How is the other part of the equation?
I said, source code is human, readable and precise, and
NOTE CONF
you will believe me, right?
But it's human, readable and should be precise, but they
NOTE CONF
never really are.
So what do I mean by that?
NOTE CONF
Um, most pre languages.
Most source.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, programme images in their definitions, even though the person
putting it together was trying to be completely precise, some
NOTE CONF
things slipped their attention.
Sometimes it's set their attention on purpose, sometimes not on
NOTE CONF
purpose.
But there's a level of precision the machine absolutely needs
NOTE CONF
that humans keep feeling like they wanna skip over.
And so yeah, his finger.
NOTE CONF
That's right, it is.
And so positioning, no ill legality.
NOTE CONF
So source codes can have ambiguities in them, and the
human might not see that they're there.
NOTE CONF
And we need this process just to resolve those ambiguities
for us.
NOTE CONF
Because by time we get the machine code.
There definitely can't be ambiguities.
NOTE CONF
So let me give you an example of an ambiguity
you might not have thought of, Uh, this code up
NOTE CONF
I have didn't restart it.
Just put it up.
NOTE CONF
So I can't tell you.
Actually, if this is ambiguous in Java, but I'll use
NOTE CONF
Java syntax, which is like C syntax, right?
Uh, void food in a NB the time a plus
NOTE CONF
B And then my main method or whatever it is,
stop asking me to install things.
NOTE CONF
Um, this code's getting close to jumping the shark.
I'll tell you what with all those pop up boxes
NOTE CONF
and stuff, Um, and then maybe I call this method,
I'll say, uh, what are we gonna do?
NOTE CONF
We're doing this in Java.
So it's system dot out dot print line for three
NOTE CONF
plus four eight divided by two.
That's direct.
NOTE CONF
Divided by zero.
Uh, actually, do this one.
NOTE CONF
This will be fun.
Hey, there you go.
NOTE CONF
So that seems like a weird piece of code to
write, but it does let me show off, uh, the
NOTE CONF
ambiguity.
So I have to find the function.
NOTE CONF
It can't return void.
It's got to return in.
NOTE CONF
I've to find a function that returns in takes in
two parameters, and it just actually returns the first one
NOTE CONF
and ignores the second one for some stupid reason.
Maybe it's a bug.
NOTE CONF
Whatever.
And then I called that function, passing it two things.
NOTE CONF
I passed the three plus four, which should be seven,
and I passed the eight divided by zero.
NOTE CONF
It should be an error, so we would expect this
code to error and not run.
NOTE CONF
Right?
OK, but there's some ambiguity here, but we expect that
NOTE CONF
code to error and not run because of an assumption
we've made, which is that both those actual parameters are
NOTE CONF
calculated before they get passed in to the function.
And you're like, Well, duh, obviously not.
NOTE CONF
Obviously, it's not obvious a computer could decide not to
do that.
NOTE CONF
It is possible all of the logic of this can
be run if you don't calculate them before you pass
NOTE CONF
them in.
If a computer would to would be to say ah
NOTE CONF
so that line five is the same as well.
It's the same as like maybe I'm in lighting.
NOTE CONF
The function is the term OK, You would think that
anywhere where you've got a function that's just got a
NOTE CONF
single line, that where the function call is you could
replace it with that single line logically makes sense.
NOTE CONF
But if I do that, I end up with this
not valid Java.
NOTE CONF
But you know what I mean?
And all of a sudden there's no errors left in
NOTE CONF
the programme.
So there were two possible ways to get from the
NOTE CONF
start of the programme to the end, one of which
seems weird to you because you're used to being a
NOTE CONF
Java programme.
But it is a perfectly valid choice, leads to no
NOTE CONF
errors and the other one which is when you used
to.
NOTE CONF
So it seemed obvious to you which leads to errors.
And so the extra precision that the source language should
NOTE CONF
have that maybe it doesn't have is the answer to
that question.
NOTE CONF
When I'm calling a function, should I evaluate the parameters
before I pass them in?
NOTE CONF
Or should I evaluate the parameters after I pass them
in and then Secondly, when I evaluate them, should I
NOTE CONF
evaluate them?
In what order?
NOTE CONF
Left to right, alphabetical Whatever order is fastest for you.
You I don't know.
NOTE CONF
There's these little subtle questions that come up that actually
get glossed over on the source codes in really good
NOTE CONF
languages, you can look it up and find the answer.
I bet in general you can find the answer to
NOTE CONF
that.
We know in general for sure that errors, because we
NOTE CONF
know for sure it does it before it goes in.
We don't know for sure which order it calculates them
NOTE CONF
in, um, so that could be left out.
And so there is some precision and some ambiguity removed
NOTE CONF
as we move from source code to machine code.
Now the removal of that ambiguity is obviously just completely
NOTE CONF
described in the Interpreter.
The interpreter makes all those decisions, so it's definitely it's
NOTE CONF
not really ambiguity.
It's in there somewhere, but you might have to go
NOTE CONF
deep into an interpreter to find out the answer.
Well, it's really good languages.
NOTE CONF
There's no ambiguity left over in the source code, so
we are actually just gaining efficiency by translating it into
NOTE CONF
another form.
So we're trading off human understand ability on machine code.
NOTE CONF
We just throw it out the window so that we
can make it more efficient if we want to.
NOTE CONF
Whereas on source code, we definitely don't throw out human
understand ability, because that's a key part of that.
NOTE CONF
That language interface.
The human understands it, and the computer understands it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so in making that translation across, um, sometimes we
translate all the way to machine code.
NOTE CONF
A Shinko literally means the op codes that your CPU
will know how to operate on.
NOTE CONF
But alternately, we could translate it to what's generally called
bytecode.
NOTE CONF
Bytecode is an invented machine code.
It's not the one your CPU runs on, but your
NOTE CONF
computer probably has another piece of software on there that
can run that as if it was CPU code.
NOTE CONF
So layer on layer programming works like this.
The layers grow and grow and grow.
NOTE CONF
So instead of directly going to the CPU, it goes
to another small programme on your computer.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but it looks just the same as one of
these CPU codes.
NOTE CONF
So that's what Bytecode would be, um, but then also
potentially, you could translate from one source code high level
NOTE CONF
language into a different high level language and remove all
of the ambiguity and just run that.
NOTE CONF
In that case, instead of running it directly on the
hardware like you can code or directly in a very
NOTE CONF
small programme that does the hard work for you, you're
running it in a larger programme that does the hard
NOTE CONF
work for you.
And that larger programme tends to be called an interpreter.
NOTE CONF
So when the machine running the code is running on
source code or high level language, we'll tend to call
NOTE CONF
it an interpreter.
When it's running on the B it will take call
NOTE CONF
it a virtual machine, and when it's running directly on
the machine, we'll tend to call it hardware.
NOTE CONF
Um, and I use phrases like tend to call it
because there's grey areas in between.
NOTE CONF
And in fact there's no distinguish between them in reality.
OK, that make sense?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So the so we're like a So there's three options
NOTE CONF
here you got.
You convert it to high level language by code or
NOTE CONF
machine code.
So what's the advantage?
NOTE CONF
P?
And the advantage of bytecode is that, um, because it's
NOTE CONF
not tied to particular hardware that byte code is transferable
across multiple hardwares.
NOTE CONF
The downside, though, is that you then have to put
that little programme on all of those machines.
NOTE CONF
This is what Java java goes for.
Byte code.
NOTE CONF
So the trade off is more portability of the output,
but the more work making it run on different machines.
NOTE CONF
Uh, he got zero work to make it run on
the machine, but it's tied to the one machine you
NOTE CONF
output for these days.
In fact, um, Intel and a MD have written tiny
NOTE CONF
little virtual machines on their CP US, and so you
never really get the machine code.
NOTE CONF
But if if the a MD and Intel chip are
accepting it, we'll call it machine code.
NOTE CONF
Uh uh.
But bytecode is by far the most popular option now
NOTE CONF
for new languages.
Almost all languages will go to bytecode.
NOTE CONF
Uh, python is a kind of halfway between.
It's halfway between source code and high level language.
NOTE CONF
Um, what other languages of Java is there?
C and C++ definitely get there.
NOTE CONF
What other language can we think of the languages of
the league?
NOTE CONF
We'll get to them like that.
I javascript sits Until 10 years ago, it sat in
NOTE CONF
source code JavaScript now sits in I coded thanks to
something called a a jit compiler that, um, Google invented.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So keep in mind, though, that you know when
we run, we can run source code directly.
NOTE CONF
We didn't actually have to compile it into anything, and
that's what an interpreter does.
NOTE CONF
That's what we're writing.
We're writing an interpreter, but we'll write an interpreter that
NOTE CONF
does.
Standing pausing creates a syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
It'll do a little bit of analysis as well, and
then it'll run a high level language, in a sense.
NOTE CONF
So along the way, uh, scanning parts are just taking,
uh, characters that you and I can understand and turning
NOTE CONF
them into more abstract concepts for the computer to work
with instead of individual characters.
NOTE CONF
But he's drawn that syntax tree and that intermediate representation
towards the top of the mountain, because once you get
NOTE CONF
it into those forms, you can see much more about
the programme.
NOTE CONF
You can write programmes that analyse that programme and make
sense of it, and we'll be doing that.
NOTE CONF
Then, after you've done that analysis, which tends to convert
it into into media representation, you might optimise that which
NOTE CONF
can stay to me as a patient I and then
after that, you'll start spitting it up the output.
NOTE CONF
If your output is another high level language, so be
it by code.
NOTE CONF
So be it in the machine code.
Just get that out.
NOTE CONF
But those phases are called code generation and and he
notes that if you are just going to another high
NOTE CONF
level language, it tends to get called transpiring instead of
compiling.
NOTE CONF
But again, with these are very furry edges on all
of these all of these contracts.
NOTE CONF
But that's one reason I like this diagram because it
helps to.
NOTE CONF
They put them, put them in.
But you can have long arguments about whether something is
NOTE CONF
transpiring or compiling or interpreting or compiling or a bit
of both.
NOTE CONF
But whether something is a high level language or a
low level language like these are religious discussions as much
NOTE CONF
as anything.
But we do try to put it's along the spectrum,
NOTE CONF
and I can you know, I can put the buckets
along the spectrum, and so it probably falls mostly in
NOTE CONF
that bucket.
So we're gonna do a whistle stop tour of all
NOTE CONF
of the phases.
We implement all these phases, we go on to scanning
NOTE CONF
in week three.
But the first phase is to take the characters of
NOTE CONF
the programme and to bundle them up into called tokens.
Uh, so I should say one of the reasons we
NOTE CONF
do this in P is where my father is up.
It is theoretically feasible to not have any phases to
NOTE CONF
just interpret a language all in one big blob.
Uh, but it's impossible and logically for the human to
NOTE CONF
get their head around it, even just for the human.
We break it into steps where each step takes one
NOTE CONF
form and converts it to the next form.
And we understand both those forms and we understand the
NOTE CONF
small programme converting.
And then we drop that one and we think, OK,
NOTE CONF
next form converts to the next one.
I don't have to think about the first one anymore.
NOTE CONF
I can just think about these two and the conversion
between them.
NOTE CONF
So, just for the programme, if that's necessary, it's necessary
also for the sorry, the programmer writing the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
It's also necessary for the programmer who's writing the programming
language because they're running in the programming language because they're
NOTE CONF
gonna get errors from the compiler, and they have to
make sense out of those errors.
NOTE CONF
So the compiler has to be structured in some way
that the ultimate programmer can understand its messages.
NOTE CONF
So you'll be used to seeing messages from your compiler
that come from the scanning phase missing semicolon or whatever.
NOTE CONF
Are they scanning phase?
You'll be used to getting ones from the scanning slash
NOTE CONF
passing phase and treating them differently to ones that come
from the type analysis phase.
NOTE CONF
And you've got internally an idea that it has to
scan and piles and then type analyse and the match
NOTE CONF
between your understanding of what the compiler is doing and
what the compiler is doing is important just for understanding
NOTE CONF
a fairness.
So both those humans need to know that.
NOTE CONF
But then finally, also for, uh, the computer side of
things.
NOTE CONF
Breaking it up like that creates flexibility down the road.
So maybe my source language is exactly the same.
NOTE CONF
But I wanna add an optimisation if I've got everything
in little sections.
NOTE CONF
Adding a new optimisation is is separated from the other
parts and much simpler if I wanna add, I'm currently,
NOTE CONF
uh compiling it for X, 86 and I want to
compile it for arm as well.
NOTE CONF
If it was all one blob, I'd have to start
the whole blob from scratch.
NOTE CONF
But by breaking it up, I can just go.
Oh, just the back bit has to be written again
NOTE CONF
and the rest can all stay the same.
So for all those reasons, compiler interpreters are these constant
NOTE CONF
phases from one known form to the next boom boom.
So we're going source code tokens, pastry, intermediate representation output.
NOTE CONF
OK, that's what we'll be doing.
So scanning goes from source code to tokens and tokens
NOTE CONF
are just bigger chunks.
But they're the chunks you and I always think about
NOTE CONF
when we're programming.
When you see bar space average, you really think bars
NOTE CONF
one unit average is another unit.
When you see average with no space next and equals
NOTE CONF
you in your head, think of the average as one
thing and equals as another.
NOTE CONF
You're not just putting on spaces.
Yeah, you're putting on a bunch of things in your
NOTE CONF
head and you know that the equals is not a
part of the average.
NOTE CONF
And you know that the parenthesis there is not a
part of the equal.
NOTE CONF
So the scanner goes and does that for the for
the programme and you get tokens to the to the
NOTE CONF
programme and they should be the ones you, uh I'm
just gonna push on.
NOTE CONF
By the way, if we were going for three hours,
I'd take a break now, but we'll be done in
NOTE CONF
two, so I'll just push through.
Yeah, OK, The next step with passing is to take
NOTE CONF
all those tokens and to relate them to each other.
So you and I know that the Min Max there
NOTE CONF
are arguments to the plus, but that's not visible up
there.
NOTE CONF
But by the time we've got to what's called the
power tree, the M and Macs are attached to the
NOTE CONF
plus.
So the structure of the programming is much clearer here,
NOTE CONF
and this structure is well, this is the right structure,
but you might Well, you will have to practise seeing
NOTE CONF
the programme in the structure instead of seeing it in
that structure.
NOTE CONF
Deep in your mind, this structure exists, but you might
not ever give it attention.
NOTE CONF
And now we gotta really start giving it attention.
So this syntax three a ST version of the programme
NOTE CONF
is probably the key one in this course.
Because once you get to this point, all that stuff
NOTE CONF
opens up for you and getting to this point.
Uh, if you get that wrong, you probably get Did
NOTE CONF
you accidentally attach the max to the parentheses?
For example, the programme means something different.
NOTE CONF
This Max has to be attached to the blood.
And if you accidentally attach the parenthesis to the divide,
NOTE CONF
which is what you might actually do because they're right
next to each other, that's not what the programme should
NOTE CONF
look like.
But the divide should be attached to the plus, which
NOTE CONF
is actually three tokens to the left.
So parsing is our parsing algorithm is an algorithm that
NOTE CONF
takes that first one turns into the second one.
After pausing, we do what's called static analysis.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we're up at the top of the mountain
and then we're analysing our programme static analysis, uh, things
NOTE CONF
you'll be familiar with.
They are name checking.
NOTE CONF
The name checking is checking that you're only using variables
that exist, and it's actually as well as checking the
NOTE CONF
only using a variable that exists.
It's checking when it sees a variable use which variable
NOTE CONF
declaration Is it attached to?
Because, you know we can We can have variables with
NOTE CONF
the same name, but they shadow each other.
So the ANA the static analysis has to go and
NOTE CONF
connect each variable used to a variable declaration.
Um, the next thing that happens is types tend to
NOTE CONF
happen.
Is this typing?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
So we're in Java.
NOTE CONF
We're used to getting type errors.
That's a static analysis phase.
NOTE CONF
It has to go through and make sure when we
use a variable, we're using it in the correct way.
NOTE CONF
And that's one of the more complicated parts of analysis
in a compiler.
NOTE CONF
And when we're actually skipping in this course, uh, well,
at least they're skipping in the text.
NOTE CONF
I suspect a little bit of type analysis in our
extension of los.
NOTE CONF
That sounds like fun.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Uh, locks doesn't have types of need type amounts, but
that's another static check that happens.
NOTE CONF
So this is the analysis at the top of the
mountain type analysis, OK, and all that tends to happen
NOTE CONF
on the abstract Syntex tree.
The thing we saw before the next step again, which
NOTE CONF
J locks won't do, it'll work directly off the A
ST is that the compiler could transmit to another intermediate
NOTE CONF
representation halfway between the abstract syntax tree and the final
output, which is byte code or machine code or another
NOTE CONF
high level.
There's very little optimisation you can do on an abstract
NOTE CONF
Syntex.
There is some, but it's very little uh, so you
NOTE CONF
tend to have to convert it to another form that
just starts to bring some of the execution details up
NOTE CONF
to the surface.
I and then you can optimise on that form.
NOTE CONF
It's optimising, in case we don't realise it's just changing
a programme so that it runs faster without changing any
NOTE CONF
of its behaviour work through.
So an easy optimisation you can do on a path
NOTE CONF
tree is if you see plus zero, you can throw
away the plus zero.
NOTE CONF
Do anything if your time one.
You can throw away the time one, but hopefully some
NOTE CONF
of you might have thought, Can you really?
Can you really throw away a plus zero?
NOTE CONF
Come to think of a situation we con atmospheric and,
uh, just one thought.
NOTE CONF
I think of something else.
If your language allows operator overloading some languages, do CPOs
NOTE CONF
costos, for example, plus doesn't have to mean, Plus, it
does.
NOTE CONF
It does it by default.
But you can redefine plus so that for example, instead
NOTE CONF
of one plus zero equaling 11 plus zero equals the
string of one and zero jam next to each other,
NOTE CONF
you can turn plus into concatenation, so the past tree
actually probably doesn't have enough information for that.
NOTE CONF
Um, but if you are just talking about interviews, if
you don't have overloading a plus, then a plus zero
NOTE CONF
is safe to throw it.
Uh, but let's give you a flavour, the kinds of
NOTE CONF
things that have to be bubbled to the surface for
the optimisation to be able to happen.
NOTE CONF
And and that's really the way to think about each
of these internal forms if they're bringing to the surface
NOTE CONF
the thing that's most important at this phase of the
compiler and then we're converting it to another form that
NOTE CONF
it brings to the surface.
One reason you don't see a picture of intermediate representation
NOTE CONF
here is because they tend to be very specific to
the language in question.
NOTE CONF
Uh, tokens are always the same.
Pastries are always the same.
NOTE CONF
Annotated past trees are almost always the same But once
we get to implement reputations, we see very different ones
NOTE CONF
for different languages.
And finally, the cogeneration cogeneration will tend to.
NOTE CONF
If you're an interpreter, it will, uh, work through the
abstract syntax tree and just interpret it as it goes.
NOTE CONF
If it is a compiler, it'll work through the intermediate
representation and convert that into the final output, which is
NOTE CONF
either byte code or machine code.
It could be another high level language sometimes, Uh, that
NOTE CONF
tends to be less common these days because there are
so many widely used bike codes now.
NOTE CONF
So most machines these days?
Uh, well, actually, no, not not.
NOTE CONF
Not most machines will have a, um, a AJ VM
byte code.
NOTE CONF
But most machines these days will have an LLVM byte
code, Um, which is another type of virtual machine that's
NOTE CONF
a little bit like the JVM that you haven't had
to play with before.
NOTE CONF
But for historical reasons, it exists in most places, including
on, um, places where JD MS don't exist like all
NOTE CONF
the apple stuff.
Uh, and so you can fairly reliably spit out LLVM
NOTE CONF
and have your code run in most places these days.
So the the the use case of spitting out another
NOTE CONF
high level language like C.
That's something you might have done in the past.
NOTE CONF
You might have converted your language through to C because
C could probably be compiled on any machine is a
NOTE CONF
bit less important than it used to be.
OK, And as I described it before, right, the the
NOTE CONF
best way I want you to think about this in
terms of you've you've heard of virtual machines before.
NOTE CONF
And you used them, of course, because you write in
Java, so you know there's a Java virtual machine.
NOTE CONF
You know when you type Java, the Java virtual machine
starts up and reads your class file and runs your
NOTE CONF
programme.
But you probably have a strong idea of what this
NOTE CONF
type of virtual machine is or why it's there.
It's that along this spectrum would build, it's possible to
NOTE CONF
spit out just the machine code and nothing else.
The machine code for your programme and nothing else that
NOTE CONF
really only happens in sea land.
Most likely, you'll spit out the gene code and it'll
NOTE CONF
be bundled up with some useful code that every single
programme in this language ever written gets it'll be something
NOTE CONF
like a description of what system do out does.
So there will be the machine code for your programme,
NOTE CONF
plus the machine code that every single programme has to
get.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, it can't run or you'll fill out bytecode and
there'll be a pre-existing virtual machine ready to run your
NOTE CONF
bytecode or you'll speed up high level language and there'll
be a pre-existing interpreter that's gonna run it for you.
NOTE CONF
So over here, where we were just spitting out machine
code that was just machine code.
NOTE CONF
Next one over gets called runtime.
That extra machine code being spit out and bundled up
NOTE CONF
is called the Run Time.
It's identical for every programme that comes out of that
NOTE CONF
programming language, Um, and so we can think of it
as a thing.
NOTE CONF
You know, if I've got any, does C++ have the
run time?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, it does.
But let's think of another language.
NOTE CONF
Um, what languages have run times that people use these
days?
NOTE CONF
We'll go with C++.
Every C++ programme that gets compiled has the exact same
NOTE CONF
runtime bundle with it, so I can say the C++
run time, even though it's in all the different and
NOTE CONF
the run time tends to do things like, uh, start
up the programme and call the main and and little
NOTE CONF
bits of bookkeeping that are needed.
And then the next one over is called.
NOTE CONF
Once you've moved away from a run time where it's
bundled up in the compiled machine code to a separate
NOTE CONF
programme on the machine that's running your byte code.
Then we tend to call out a virtual machine.
NOTE CONF
And then again, once we get further up, we'll tend
to call them interpreters instead of virtual.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, OK, any questions and we do need to get
those phrases right.
NOTE CONF
OK, so it is possible to write a single pass
compiler, which just goes straight from the source code and
NOTE CONF
interprets the code.
As I said, I explained why that was the best
NOTE CONF
thing to do.
A very common point in the programme, and the one
NOTE CONF
that we're gonna write is the tree walk interpreter.
That's one where you do scanning and passing into an
NOTE CONF
a ST.
You do some analysis on the A ST, and then
NOTE CONF
you interpret the A ST directly.
It's an easy way to write an interpreter and a
NOTE CONF
really good way when you're writing these little languages.
So I remember back at the start, we said, Why
NOTE CONF
are we even doing this?
It's because we might want to write these little languages
NOTE CONF
as a part of our job.
You definitely don't want the long, hard, efficient path for
NOTE CONF
your little language.
You want the shortest, effective path that comes to be
NOTE CONF
the key Walk to and the scanning Passing and a
ST are always the same through technology along the way
NOTE CONF
and your questions that you have to ask yourself when
you're writing little languages, What does my language look like?
NOTE CONF
And how do I pass that?
And then what's the meaning of that?
NOTE CONF
And how do I walk?
The interpreter and everything else is just running the pattern.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna write a scanner.
I'm gonna write a parser.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna create an EST.
As I said, transpire is the word for when you
NOTE CONF
take one thing that a human can read and commit
it to another thing.
NOTE CONF
A human can read.
The most common types of transpire is transpiring to C,
NOTE CONF
and if you've programmed C, you'll know there's a generous
definition of what a human can read and the fact
NOTE CONF
that compilers and interpreters overlap a lot.
I've said that quite a bit, but he makes the
NOTE CONF
point of a a fruit and vegetable analogy, which is
pretty good.
NOTE CONF
Now we'll just talk a little bit about Do they
come up?
NOTE CONF
Jit compilers.
I I've used that phrase already, and Java is a
NOTE CONF
jit compiler, so you might be wondering what a jit
compiler does or a jit virtual machine.
NOTE CONF
Whatever you've heard, Jit right Java's Jit Javascript's a jit
these days.
NOTE CONF
What's a jit?
Who knows what Jit stands for?
NOTE CONF
Just in time.
So what it really means is that I delay some
NOTE CONF
of these steps and I do them at the time.
I really need to, um, but it's nice to know
NOTE CONF
exactly where J tends to mean something that spread out
of byte code that could still get some efficiency gains
NOTE CONF
if instead it was spitting out machine code.
And so the virtual machine that is running over the
NOTE CONF
byte code instead of just running bytecode.
Like every other virtual machine in the world, it sometimes
NOTE CONF
stops and runs a code generation phase to create machine
code that it can run, and it sometimes just runs
NOTE CONF
the code like it normally does sometimes stops and compiles
it.
NOTE CONF
It does another step to get it down to machine
code.
NOTE CONF
Uh, that it can then reuse over and over again.
So that just in time is because it's happening right
NOTE CONF
down here at the last possible minute.
Uh, the chicken P, we don't We won't build one.
NOTE CONF
Conceptually are not that tricky Taking the same thing you
might have done any other you might have done just
NOTE CONF
once but dynamically doing it.
So maybe if the code only runs once the code
NOTE CONF
path anyone once you don't bother you, you just interpret
it.
NOTE CONF
But you get to a loop that you've just gone
around 100 times.
NOTE CONF
You're like I'm probably gonna go around this forever.
So I'm gonna I'm gonna compile this into a more
NOTE CONF
efficient form and just start looping on that more efficient
form.
NOTE CONF
And then when it spits back out, it goes back
to the interpreter and you're like, No, Well, this probably
NOTE CONF
you go back into the loop, hit it a few
times, you're like, Oh, I can do that one as
NOTE CONF
well.
And that's how Google made javascript so much faster with
NOTE CONF
the V eight compiler for JavaScript it basically in a
to jit part, one of the keys to a cool
NOTE CONF
jet.
Just as inside is that sometimes there are language features
NOTE CONF
that slow down the machine code.
Java's got a classic example, which is eval.
NOTE CONF
Python's got it, too.
Most dynamic languages have it.
NOTE CONF
V Val is a, um, a command in the language.
You can pass it a string in the language and
NOTE CONF
it will run that string.
So it's like putting the language inside the language and
NOTE CONF
you run eval, use the language, so that makes machine
code impossible because an input might be an entire Java
NOTE CONF
programme.
And you put that in an eval, and then you've
NOTE CONF
got to run the entire Java programme.
So the only way to do that is to have
NOTE CONF
an entire interpreter in inserted into the machine code.
So you end up going around in circles, I say
NOTE CONF
you go forget that we're just gonna do an interpreter.
If there's an eval, the only sensible thing to do
NOTE CONF
is an interpreter.
But if you're if you're a got a big chunk
NOTE CONF
of JavaScript code, say you're the V eight compiler and
you can see there's no evals you got it cool.
NOTE CONF
It's something like a jet.
It doesn't have any of those pesky features that are
NOTE CONF
getting in the way of my normal compilation.
So this little chunk I can jit that I'll compile
NOTE CONF
that.
And, uh, that'll run through the fast.
NOTE CONF
And because a lot of because evals are bad, people
tend not to use them.
NOTE CONF
You could possibly write and only compiled JavaScript interpreter.
But you can get a lot of efficiency gains by
NOTE CONF
saying, Ah, this this part's only using a subset of
JavaScript but it's a subset I can compile, so that's
NOTE CONF
good.
I like that cool.
NOTE CONF
OK, it's important to note that compiled versus interpreted is
not really a feature of the language itself.
NOTE CONF
It's a feature of the tooling around the language.
I did just say languages like JavaScript must be interpreted,
NOTE CONF
Um, and so you can see a few.
We never mean Inter absolutely necessarily interpret one that, um
NOTE CONF
But he suggested that for Ruby J lock and PHP,
uh, notice that he's even He hasn't just said It's
NOTE CONF
Ruby.
That's interpreted, he said.
NOTE CONF
MRI, which is one of the ruby implementations, is interpreted.
Yeah, there's another ruby implementation called ya, which is much
NOTE CONF
more like a compiler.
And so you can't say whether Ruby is interpreted or
NOTE CONF
compiled because it depends what tool you use.
Same JavaScript.
NOTE CONF
Um, but most of the real JavaScript you're using are
in between these days.
NOTE CONF
And then there's a small set of things that you
can say definitely compilers, and he's put over there.
NOTE CONF
You know, all of the implementations of rust are compilers.
Clang, which is one of the implementations of C, is
NOTE CONF
a compiler.
GCC is another implementation of C That's a compiler.
NOTE CONF
Uh, co script is a fun.
It's a trans piller, but he put transpire over there
NOTE CONF
and a compiler there.
But the key there is that it's the tooling around
NOTE CONF
it that matters.
And the other key thing is, most of them sit
NOTE CONF
in the space in between, either by virtue of being,
uh, having really big, chunky runtime or something that do
NOTE CONF
things that feel like interpreting stuff.
Yeah, so I'd say for high school and scheme, it's
NOTE CONF
the existence of a really chunky run time in there
that makes him decide it's not purely compiled.
NOTE CONF
I probably lure oh IL All right.
Questions on the map of the territory we got, right?
NOTE CONF
You can say no, I'm not going.
All right.
NOTE CONF
No one's going anything.
OK, cool as well.
NOTE CONF
Happy to help any time.
Uh, so if you are not going alright, please, uh,
NOTE CONF
make strong use of the forums.
They don't often get used a lot, but I want
NOTE CONF
you to use them a lot.
Here, Um, we try and make learning from each other
NOTE CONF
the key here rather than learning from us.
The way to think about a lecture is that I'm
NOTE CONF
pumping this material at all of you, and some of
you are getting it.
NOTE CONF
And then after this, you'll all talk to each other
until you all get it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so but that talking to each other until you
all get it is key.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but do it on the forums because then I
can chime in and just clarify things that go slightly
NOTE CONF
wrong.
And it can be available for everybody in the course
NOTE CONF
as well.
Um, so we will try to be good in terms
NOTE CONF
of keeping an eye on the forums and answering them
quickly because we think that's very good.
NOTE CONF
We know.
I learn forums aren't brilliant.
NOTE CONF
Uh, discord would be easier, blah, blah, blah.
But that's what we got for now, right?
NOTE CONF
Lastly, today, it's a lot in the first week, isn't
it?
NOTE CONF
Normally, you just do unit guide and go home, but
not today.
NOTE CONF
We included the seven languages Introduction.
Now my links to the Seven Languages book just linked
NOTE CONF
to the Amazon page for it because I can't link
inside um, the library, But you want to go via
NOTE CONF
the library to the online version of the book.
I bought a paper copy of it and I went
NOTE CONF
in my office.
Um, I wouldn't recommend that because it's just one of
NOTE CONF
those print on demand ones.
It doesn't feel very high quality, bit disappointing, um, the
NOTE CONF
introduction chapter.
So people learn second languages for all kinds of reasons,
NOTE CONF
he says.
But he also talks about the way he's going about
NOTE CONF
this.
The key to this book is that it's not trying
NOTE CONF
to replace your stack overflow Google searches for languages.
It's not trying to replace Wikipedia for the language.
NOTE CONF
It's taking an alternative approach.
The alternative he takes is that he he treats it
NOTE CONF
a bit like doing a like if you brought someone
to do it.
NOTE CONF
If you the Wikipedia page for Sydney, tells you how
many people live in Sydney, maybe it's got a list
NOTE CONF
of all the suburbs of Sydney.
And but if you bring someone to Sydney and show
NOTE CONF
them around, you just pick the highlights and you take
them to the fun bits and you give them a
NOTE CONF
feel for the city.
That's what this book tries to do for the languages
NOTE CONF
it tries to hit the highlights.
The bits that are different from other places are particularly
NOTE CONF
interesting or particularly nice and visits them, but does go
into enough detail to help you understand what you're saying.
NOTE CONF
What's the typing model?
What's the programming model, how you interact with it and
NOTE CONF
what are the design constructs and data structures?
Uh, what are the core features that make the language
NOTE CONF
unique and this allows us to compare them to each
other?
NOTE CONF
So the typing model is really important in a lot
of languages.
NOTE CONF
It's where you end up fighting with your compiler most
of the time in dealing with the typing.
NOTE CONF
Obviously, the programming model matters, and there are at least
um object oriented slash imperative slash logic slash functional slash
NOTE CONF
data flow.
Slash.
NOTE CONF
So these are all different programming paradigms that could have
languages to help you understand them.
NOTE CONF
So you're only used to imperative and object going at
this phase.
NOTE CONF
Thanks.
There's a whole other world out there I'd say 99%
NOTE CONF
of paid work.
Is that an object or imperative?
NOTE CONF
So that's fine.
But the parts of those programmes end up being logic
NOTE CONF
based, function based or data flow based, and so giving
yourself the space to understand them in a in a
NOTE CONF
specifically designed language gives you the clearest way to properly
understand the concept before you try and shoehorn it in
NOTE CONF
some other language.
So I see that a lot with functions.
NOTE CONF
I quite like Java's function Lambda syntax.
But it is so much harder to teach someone.
NOTE CONF
Lambda is in Java than it is in high school,
where high school it just works around the land is
NOTE CONF
better.
And so it creates a better environment to learn how
NOTE CONF
they work.
So you might have to go via has to properly
NOTE CONF
understand how land does work and then never, ever use
has school to deal with them.
NOTE CONF
You'd do them all in Java, but without that sidetrack
to Haskell land to properly understand what was going on,
NOTE CONF
you'd be stuck in this You a misconception on the
Java side and never really being able to use that
NOTE CONF
tool properly.
OK, so he says he does Ruby, which Ruby's such
NOTE CONF
a great fun language.
Um, I'm back into typing Ruby again, and I'm like,
NOTE CONF
Yes, Ruby is fun.
I don't know how a language can be fun, but
NOTE CONF
somehow it is IO, which is definitely a research language.
All the rest of these are commercially successful, but it's
NOTE CONF
a research language, but it's got some really some features
that are worth touching on.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, we we're not gonna skip it.
We're gonna do it.
NOTE CONF
It's it's good.
And it's a simplicity.
NOTE CONF
And, uh uh, uniform syntax.
Minimal syntax, I guess, is the key here.
NOTE CONF
I OS minimal syntax.
I'm just pointing that out because with IO you won't
NOTE CONF
be able to go and just have a package to
install it on a windows or a Mac or whatever.
NOTE CONF
You'll have to compile it yourself.
There might be Actually, I think there is a Windows
NOTE CONF
one Windows package.
Hey, a prologue.
NOTE CONF
Very old, but very important.
It's there's more than one prologue, but I think the
NOTE CONF
I think we end up using sweet prologue here.
Uh, but they're all 99% of the same.
NOTE CONF
So we touch on product Product was originally created to
help write artificial intelligence programmes back when artificial intelligence meant
NOTE CONF
searching the space of correct answers.
Now, artificial Jones means spamming.
NOTE CONF
A neural network, um, probably doesn't do that.
Prologue helps you search a space of correct answers.
NOTE CONF
It basically lays out every possible correct dancer and helps
you search it.
NOTE CONF
And I'm sure you can think of examples where searching
the space of correct answers is a problem you might
NOTE CONF
need to do in your your programme.
Life scar is built on the virtual machine that brings
NOTE CONF
it just it wants to be a It wanted to
be the bridge between functional programme and object on improving.
NOTE CONF
I think it is.
I think it does a great job of that, but
NOTE CONF
it has become a bit of a kitchen sink language.
Um, where the people working on it are very smart
NOTE CONF
people who are very good language designers, and so they
end up with the best solution to problem a and
NOTE CONF
then the best solution to problem B.
And it just keeps turning up in Scala.
NOTE CONF
And you're like, Oh, what's the best solution to index
type families?
NOTE CONF
Oh, Scar's got a good one, you know, like what
the heck is an index type family?
NOTE CONF
Well, it's one of those weird esoteric things.
What's the best solution to implicitly carrying state around?
NOTE CONF
Oh, Scala's got one that's the best.
And so it keeps accumulating the best answers.
NOTE CONF
And so that's what's keeping it around.
Um, that's why I call it a kitchen sink language,
NOTE CONF
cos whatever feature you can think of, it's probably in
Scala, Um, whereas it started off, just how do I
NOTE CONF
mesh, object on and functional in a proper way?
And it solved that problem really nicely and then has
NOTE CONF
continued solving other problems along the way.
But along with that, it it's quite complex based.
NOTE CONF
There's a lot going on.
Erlang is another very old language.
NOTE CONF
Belang stands for Erickson because it was created at the
telecommunications company to run on their switches, and it's a
NOTE CONF
super reliable, super distributed language.
So it's built around.
NOTE CONF
It should be the language of the Internet, really, in
fact, I'd say Still, a lot of airline happens on
NOTE CONF
the Internet.
And there was a time when a lot of Internet
NOTE CONF
tooling was being built with Ang because it just naturally
fit other languages.
NOTE CONF
Started catching up a lot more rabbit Rabbit MQN is
right.
NOTE CONF
I think co DB is as well.
Um, you can now simulate erlang in most other languages,
NOTE CONF
so people don't have to turn to it.
But that gives you an idea of, uh, again You
NOTE CONF
wanna learn erlang because you're gonna ultimately simulate erlang and
learning how to simulate it is hard work to go
NOTE CONF
to the source first, um, closure was basically a reim
implementation of lisp.
NOTE CONF
Um, but by doing a reim implementation of lisp under
the tutelage of this very charismatic and very a good
NOTE CONF
teacher, uh, what was his name with chicken?
Uh, closure became a a really great place for people
NOTE CONF
to learn some old school computing concepts and rediscover how
important they are.
NOTE CONF
And then high school, which is by far the most
important of all of these.
NOTE CONF
No, no, no, But I'm a high school programmer.
I love me.
NOTE CONF
Some high school, um, high school is the language that
just says its functions and functions and functions.
NOTE CONF
And I'm not going to back down.
This language is going to follow that path and come
NOTE CONF
what May and our school community over the years has
demonstrated exactly all of the benefits and downsides of functional
NOTE CONF
programming.
And if you sit in the space of those benefits,
NOTE CONF
you want to use high school.
But the key, the key contribution of house school in
NOTE CONF
its community, is delineating that space clearly over many, many
decades of hard, uh, hard engineering graft.
NOTE CONF
Um and so that's why high school programmers are great
to talk to.
NOTE CONF
It's also putting out the customs prior for existence.
Or at least one of us, for many reasons for
NOTE CONF
existence is to be the people.
Yes, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So high school came out of, uh, Cambridge in the
UK.
NOTE CONF
And it was it.
The properties that it uses.
NOTE CONF
The properties that it sticks to religiously are the properties
that make it really nice for doing computer science research.
NOTE CONF
So a lot of people in computer science research will
use has school for their work.
NOTE CONF
Uh, for those years.
OK, so let's do a quick, um, show of hands
NOTE CONF
to wake you up before we finish.
You're gonna show out of all those languages.
NOTE CONF
Which ones you're most interested in learning.
Who's most interested in learning?
NOTE CONF
Ruby I iron.
No, I take it for IO.
NOTE CONF
We got a Really?
Yep.
NOTE CONF
I'll get you to an I.
A prologue?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, it's a it's got.
It's the scale of people early and no one besides
NOTE CONF
Damon that there is another question.
Hooray!
NOTE CONF
Uh, closure.
Uh, and Haskell Yay!
NOTE CONF
I encourage.
I enthused you all about high school.
NOTE CONF
It's our last one.
Unfortunately, save the best of the last.
NOTE CONF
There's a follow up book for this.
Uh, if you really enjoy this process, you can grab
NOTE CONF
the next book and follow on.
So again, these two textbooks have been chosen so that
NOTE CONF
if you get a passion for this, you know, the
next logical step.
NOTE CONF
All right.
Exactly two hours.
NOTE CONF
Brilliant.
Almost like I know what I'm doing.
NOTE CONF
So thank you very much.
Any questions?
NOTE CONF
Before we finish up, I will make one more.
Note it down.
NOTE CONF
I know.
I heard someone open the back door down there just
NOTE CONF
before it started, so I'm guessing they're in the storage
room, OK, so and most of the people in the
NOTE CONF
microphone.
OK, thank you very much.
NOTE CONF
I shall see you and enjoy your classes this week.
Thanks, guys.
NOTE CONF
And double thanks to little Jim jam up the back
there who was obviously fascinated enough to not make any
NOTE CONF
noise.
We were James Power of Robots.
NOTE CONF
Oh, mhm.
What's got you got you 26?
NOTE CONF
Because I don't want that.
Yeah, they all over.
NOTE CONF
I want I wanna be there in the stay on
screen, so I'll just get back down there.
NOTE CONF
What about this?
And we were going to practise.
NOTE CONF
Did I said all the others at one time.
I said only I can I ask you a question?
NOTE CONF
So, um, at Beckett uni in my hometown, I, uh,
also did, like a course of the oriented and infection
NOTE CONF
programming.
Uh, and then I had to make, uh, inal as
NOTE CONF
sort of interpreter for ST Can you also like, follow
the Interpreter, interpreter or not, But it's different to what
NOTE CONF
we're gonna do here, because here, we're gonna use probably
You're doing an interpreter on the stat language.
NOTE CONF
So different language.
But that's nice.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I really enjoy it.
So it's, uh and here you probably learn other languages
NOTE CONF
as well.
And so that's nice.
NOTE CONF
Um, I said that I said Yes.
Yes, OK, so when we say it's what we mean
NOTE CONF
by computer.
So if you're talking about CPU, definitely.
NOTE CONF
But the computer has got a bunch of software on
it.
NOTE CONF
There's no reason there couldn't be a software that it
could be an interpreter running on the machine that can
NOTE CONF
then take in the initial language.
Um, so when you say there's no reason why my
NOTE CONF
computer can't have an interpreter on there that can interpret
any of the languages straight from that source code.
NOTE CONF
But if you're talking about actually the hardware and I
understand the hardware can only go around the codes, it
NOTE CONF
knows about 1000.
Nice to hear you.
NOTE CONF
I didn't need to take too much.
No, no, that was good.
NOTE CONF
But she kind of liked it.
I mean, you know, uh, Cameron and Malcolm and Mitchell
NOTE CONF
had been doing tag team lecturing.
Yeah, yeah, I.
NOTE CONF
I actually like it.
I did get a bit distracted there because, uh, I
NOTE CONF
discovered that, uh, if you every day I was having
issues with my calendar and I finally decided to fix
NOTE CONF
it.
I don't know if I actually have achieved that, but
NOTE CONF
let's see.
So you reckon it was somebody in the back?
NOTE CONF
I heard someone go.
All right.
NOTE CONF
So should I get what do you know?
Uh, I gonna go to his heart from the elevator.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
How you going, buddy?
NOTE CONF
James, how are you going now?
We're all finished.
NOTE CONF
We're finished.
Oh, what were you doing that whole time?
NOTE CONF
Ah, let's fix that now, cos we're gonna be here
for a little bit longer, but I'll be able to
NOTE CONF
unlock the Nintendo.
OK, maybe another hour or so, but not in here.
NOTE CONF
We're going out for a walk and doing fun things.
No, I have.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Uh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
We forgot to give you the code.
That's you OK?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
There's nothing obvious, but there is a plant room a
NOTE CONF
little slow there.
There was some other noises coming from it.
NOTE CONF
So I wonder if there's a dodgy boo equipment.
If that's the case, that's gonna drive them nuts, it
NOTE CONF
would drive me.
Thanks for good morning.
NOTE CONF
Pardon.
OK, I'm doing
NOTE CONF